and we'll start slow we use our way into
we're gonna start with red flag number
one and just disclaimer this one is not
going to be the funniest one but I do
think it's gonna resonate with the most
amount of people here
red flag number one is when
she had
that [__] that [__] is red flag number
one
[Applause]
[Music]
girls who don't drink enough water
that's what it is my boy up front what
what would you have to choose what would
you say is your biggest fear
scare the dark too we'll see let's go
let's go that's awesome man you and I
night light gang
this is your lady
just girlfriend did you know he was
afraid of the dark
it was a learning experience
because I know how this experience went
down he stayed over at her house and
kept the TV on and she was like how long
are you gonna watch this movie for and
it was like till the sun comes up if you
go to sleep okay
do you know what your girl's biggest
fear is
you don't know
man do you want to fill them in
fish
he feels
and that's why you can't eat [__] in
the dark
two fears coming together to make one
you guys are gonna be okay
next time she acts up bro take this
[__] to an aquarium
[Music]
if it doesn't work out remember there's
plenty of fish in the sea okay
it's cute but also manageable you know
you don't work near the dark do you
you know work a night shift or anything
where do you work my boy unfortunate law
enforcement
so you really hate the dark
[Applause]
you can beat his ass if you want to
not one person it's our house tonight
all right you can [__] him up no
consequences
[Applause]
[Laughter]
sorry you're just the only black dude
within 100 rows
thank you very much
what was your name bro Serge Sarge great
to meet you my Niagara
appreciate you so much
what might be some red flags for a guy
if you go on a date with him he says or
does this that makes you kind of be like
oh I don't know
splitting the check okay on a first date
he asked in the beginning of the date
towards the middle oh you were boring
in the middle can I get you anything
yeah two checks two checks to go yeah
yeah so where did you say you were from
how recently was this
five months ago okay and you still upset
um
where where did you where did you go to
eat
what is it
[Music]
the gin and Temple what is that
Sean is that
yeah catfish and steak
[Music]
it's like a Road House an expensive
Roadhouse okay well yeah I mean maybe
did you like him
until that moment did you like him
[Applause]
I'm curious until he asked to split the
check where you're like this is going
good
you were
[__]
[Music]
oh my gosh let me did you sleep with him
wow
[Applause]
oh my God
he split you and the check in one night
[Applause]
oh my God
did he leave a big tail
I'm originally from Columbus Ohio I
don't like everybody's ever made that
mistake I said Ohio from Ohio
it just sounds funny wait for the rest
of the show You're Gonna Lose
geography got you off like that
put this out Tallahassee
more syllables you know what
where are you from
Mexico City Mexico City nice you live
here now or are you just hiding here
[__] awesome
[__] love Mexico man I get all my
folk from there you guys do a really
good job
fantastic
what uh how long how long have you been
here yeah
see also
and people will still come up after show
saying the same angry rant every time
just [__] you you [__] you cannot
make jokes about trans people it's what
they're going through is so incomparable
and you can't imagine how hard their
life is and the [__] that they have to
go through therefore you cannot make
jokes about trans people and and I I
hear you I hear you loud and clear
look
but
the point that you're trying to make is
you're saying I can't make jokes about
somebody because of how hard their life
is and you are making very valid points
in that I don't know how hard that life
is I imagine it is tremendously harder
than my life I can't imagine how hard
that is to go through and I wish you the
best of luck
at the same time to retort that argument
you also don't have
the hardest life you know who has life
way harder than trans people that we
never talk about
people in wheelchairs
comparatively people wheelchairs have a
much harder life do they complain about
it no we gave them a couple of ramps and
kept it pushing we [__] it
some people are gonna think this is an
insensitive comparison I think it's a
step in the right direction personally I
think I think if we want to head towards
trans equality we [__] start with
better parking you know it's it's the
least we could do it's the least we
could do I don't know where we put them
we can't assign them anything
foreign
[Applause]
do not get sensitive now don't [__]
sit there and feel like you need to
defend the wheelchair Community they can
[__] stand up for themselves okay but
God damn it you guys
look if you're still upset about the
comparison
feel free to think about it and tell me
I'm wrong
let's say you did let's let's say you
took somebody with with no legs
and a trans person
and you put them in the same room the
same handicap accessible room
see who you think has the harder life
I just
I feel like I'm trapped inside of
another person's body
so you have four legs
you're not listening it's not about that
it's a sometimes my mental health will
take such a toll but I could just
I could just jump off of my balcony
jump
what's that
you're you're not here people will call
me the wrong pronouns
someone called me Chariot Tubman the
other day you think
I think a pronoun's the worst thing you
can be called
come on
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh you mean transportation
[Music]
[Applause]
right now
you're scheduling some dick what are you
doing
what's the mode
you were just looking that's worse
who exactly right now
he was just looking at who's Tech I saw
the I saw the blue bubbles on there
foreign
who was it
who's more important than me right now I
want to know who's number one in your
life right now who is it
you were just looking at what it better
be pictures of me
could have been my Instagram show me if
it was me
and [__] don't you scroll to another
app I swear to God if you open another
app
you want to be real
be present
what is your name Lana
you're saying exactly what I'm saying
Lana
did I not just [__] say that
spell it
l-o-r-n-a Lorna
yeah
not even a real name I see why you
missing
Lorna
what's your last name the Rings
[__] nerds whatever
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you drove 200 miles from me to sit on
your phone
[Applause]
were you checking directions for the
drive back is that what it was
um
that was just four vowels in a row
[Laughter]
British people just say [__] consonants
dude
look at me in my Bowl
bro who the [__] are you people dude
say letters
you just dip on half the word sometimes
what do you do
fire you're a buyer of
we're all buyers
because you won't even say what is it
people like what is
I'm not bad could it possibly be
I find aluminum
[Laughter]
she just said something that was so not
a word
aluminum
you're all dead you're all so dead dude
oh [__] y'all man that's not a word
damn
where are all the extra letters coming
you're doing too much all the aluminum
no [__] that guys you're wrong I'm
Dr the m
nope not gonna do this right now you're
not gonna you don't make me look stupid
[Applause]
aluminum foreign
[__] you guys dude you get one word
right and you think you're [__] hot
[__]
[Applause]
how long are you
seven months oh my God
oh my God it hurts right
if you could compare like a guy having
to go through like what do you think we
would have to go through to to
experience something like that
anal
doesn't sound that bad
[Applause]
I think it's a lot worse than angle I
would imagine I don't think it's a
different pay I mean you've taken a big
[__] before you know
it's basically anal you know what I mean
every dude in here is taking a [__] so
big that you're like I could be gay
this was light work you know what I mean
nothing bro
[Applause]
stop it
no
Mila and Roberto Roberto Roberto Umberto
sure
I haven't heard that one before okay
what about you um
what are you doing
you're a sheriff for real
I didn't mean anything I said
I was just [__] around here
it's a cool name
you've never shot anybody
shot in somebody
[Applause]
does that scare you about him like
having to have a job like that that's so
dangerous it's beautiful
Jesus Christ
especially in the dark I can't even bite
you back there
thank you
Jesus Christ
see what I mean
what what
you ain't a [__] but act like one
foreign
[Applause]
kids
wait are you Latina yeah yeah good luck
oh my God
can't have any kids dying alone 100
absolutely not are you kidding me
you're too young forgets how old are you
30.
I don't know how much you remember about
health class but
you're almost too old for kids
[Applause]
there's more people in this room than
you have eggs left I don't know if you
know that
[Applause]
sorry Latino huevos I don't know how
many huevos
[Music]
thank you
whenever I go home for Christmas I stay
with my grandpa
and I love my grandpa to death he's
probably the closest person to me and my
family and I love staying with him
because whenever I'm not there he he
lives by himself
and my grandpa's lived alone for like 15
years
it's a single 15 years hasn't been on a
date in 15 years as you can imagine
carpal tunnel is on its way
and because he's lived alone for so long
he's kind of become this like crotchety
grumpy old man he doesn't like anything
or anybody's complains all day long you
all know an old person like this so he's
always the hardest hardest to shop for
for Christmas every year so two years
ago it's mid-December right I'm at my
place in La I'm getting ready to go home
you know finishing up all my online
shopping and it gets down to him every
year I'm sitting there just
racking my brain I'm like what the [__]
do I get this dude he he doesn't like
anything he doesn't like anybody he
doesn't have anybody
so I bought him a pocket [__]
normally normally I would be like does
anybody not know what a pocket bus is
but this is Sixth Street y'all be
[__] banana peels
whatever y'all can find out here y'all
ain't no position to judge my family
okay
bro I just wish y'all could have been
there to see him open it on Christmas
morning because we all thought he was
gonna be like what the [__] is this [__]
he was like thank you
do what I needed I was like it's a it's
a flashlight not a Purple Heart dawg
relax okay stop feeling so honored
and then we fast forward a little bit
now we fast forward to that following
February and I hadn't spoken to my
grandpa since Christmas so I call him up
hey Steve
Stephen what's up man how you doing I
love you I miss you my Christmas was fun
it's always good to spend the holidays
with you you know
how was it
and there was just a silence
on his end of the phone I was like are
you using it right now like [__]
answer me dog like what's what's the
review you know I'm I'm interested he
goes
he gets all defensive and I'll never
forget these words for as long as I live
he goes no no no no no no no I uh I
broke her neck
so much to unpack
in that one sentence first of all her
you gave it a pronoun now it's real
second neck that's not even what it is
and third you broke it dog how hard are
you going [__] 15 years you forget
how to be a gentleman
so we we laughed on the phone for a
couple of hours and that now we fast
forward to the following Christmas this
is last Christmas again same time of
year going home finishing up shopping
gets down to him so now I'm really
struggling I'm like what the [__] do I
get to miss here like like how do I
possibly top what I did last year you
know clearly he enjoyed it and now my
man hasn't had [__] since at least
February
so uh I doubled down got him another one
I got him two pocket [__] two
Christmases in a row I'm grandson of the
decade easily only well you know
you know obviously I was a little bit
more aware of what it was going to be
put through this time around I had to
find it more and more durable right you
know something with a stronger neck
you know now I'm out here trying to find
a pocket [__] with traps
and I [__] I couldn't find I couldn't
find exactly what I was looking for I
was so mad and then I I think I found
the next best thing I I found this other
Pocket [__] that I've never seen
anything like it was remarkable it it
came with it was like so souped up it
came with
in peace
in peace it was like a Swiss Army [__]
it had to be a compass and a can opener
and it doubles as a canteen if you're
lost in the woods I guess
but by far the best attachment this
thing came with was that like if you
if you like let's say you [__] this
side of it right like this is the
entrance
this side of it is a suction cup
the idea being you can [__]
[Music]
put into walls and [__] if you need to I
don't know switch positions work your
legs you know whatever it is you feel
like you need it added to your
repertoire you know and I I got it for
him thinking like yo this is so creative
you know I mean now my man's got free
roam at the house you know he's not he's
not bed bound beating his dick like a
pilgrim he's got options you know what I
mean so I was excited for him but now
I'm [__] terrified to go home this
Christmas and there's just gonna be
chunks of drywall missing all around the
house
waist level
doing a bit of remodeling are we
his house looks like a mid demo project
like ah damn Papaw you literally [__]
from the window to the wall
so dick sucked down the hall
oh Steve Steve Steve Steve
he's disgusting
but he's funny man he's very funny I
called him about a month ago and I told
him I was gonna start telling this story
on stage because
it's 100 true and I think the world
should know that
and he's got such a good sense of humor
man he was joking with me back he was
like
you keep telling people that story
I'm Gonna Leave it to you in my will
which I think would be [__] hilarious
I told him that was like yo you should
do that because I'll [__] I'll put
your ashes in it name it Ashley and then
I'll [__] it just kind of keep it in the
family you know what I mean just from
generation to generation
just so he can meet his great grandkids
you know
guys it's called cremation grow up okay
[Applause]
take my belt on
if I do will you hang yourself with it
I've never been more sure somebody from
Miami
worse
what school you go to
Community College
it's a private school sorry
just say you came for money just say
that
Paltrow's jury selection is that a real
thing
wasn't she sell them [__] scented
candles
holistic stuff she's a Blog
the goop that sounds like what she named
her [__] sense of candles
I wish I had been more up to date on
that trial
now that we
've come that's [__] scary
[Laughter]
oh way worse women's basketball
yeah
[Laughter]
what's that
your mom plays professional basketball
no way so you definitely don't come from
money
[Applause]
I did something your mom could never do
I dumped on your [__] ass dog
[Applause]
that was a low blow on the side but it
was also such a layup you know was your
mom good would you say she was the dikel
Jordan of the WWE
[Music]
[Laughter]
that is pretty cool though did you get
to go to a lot of games growing up
you sat courtside
was it lonely
we have to get out of here you guys
we do because I have a fantasy WNBA team
to go Mainland who fought on the way
over here all right y'all are clearly a
couple who who who's the guy in her life
that you hate
it's her best friends
where'd you meet this best friend
at work oh that's worse
oh no she has to see him every day
okay where do you work
at a school are you a teacher
oh [__] okay all right okay okay what do
you teach
what is he a teacher as well
what does he teach
science would you say you two have
chemistry
no we
doesn't sound like it
sounds like y'all are about to be
history
[Applause]
biologically what were you born female
I appreciate [__] what's your name
Charlie where you go by Axel ooh the
gangster ass thing hug you land how'd
you land on axel
because you let your best friend pick
your name oh my God I couldn't never my
best friends would like your name baby
dick
who chose the name
how did you how did you land on axel
now you feel like a transmission
gay like gay gay
super yeah
what's your name man Andre
you're the first White Andre I've ever
met tonight
are you serious you're 37 you look
fantastic
oh I gotta get gay
you look incredible Matt what's the
secret see you man
um
young dudes maybe don't say that
[Laughter]
37 you look great you're in good shape
single guy what do you do work wise
what's the fun part about it
money
you can suck dick for more I'm sure I
don't know I don't know how much
marketing salaries pay but only fans I
know I know some [__] who have houses
you can sell feet pictures for more now
this is interesting
have you sold feet picks before
dirty socks you mailed dirty socks to
people for how much
why are you applauding
foreign
[Music]
would you buy your family socks
every kid when they were younger got
socks for Christmas and they were like
ah now it's an investment
that scares you
[Applause]
God damn
that was so rude and accurate
he's not [__] Freddie Mercury though
he's gonna be all right
are you on prep Andre he is he's doing
just fine do you know somebody who has
AIDS
for herself
unless she's not strong enough
that's an AIDS accurate joke [__] you
guys like I brought it up you know
what's funny I did a whole school
shooting joke earlier and you guys wow
ah AIDS gets brought up me boy like this
show is a nightmare
where the [__] is your guys's line
got me shook a little bit
I should feel comfortable man I'm gonna
[__] settle Back to the Future right
now that's the only coolest places you
can get to perform forgive me if I seem
a little shaky I'm doing my best Michael
J fox impression
how do I follow AIDS you guys
let me try to get out of it Jesus Christ
man Andre
other than AIDS
what's what scares you
girls ew right
some of them are annoying
[Applause]
is my ex here what the [__]
whoa who's that small dick okay all
right well first of all what's small
I need a measurement from the base
so if you tell me wait tell me when to
stop ready tell me where to stop
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god [__] lower your standards
he's his owner was higher at this point
your standards are your servants Jesus
right
right so you be like you you need above
like eight inches has to be above eight
oh my God what if he's like really funny
is this is this a a guy you dated
recently
you're married
what oh the giant did what's what what's
the ethnicity of your husband
he's white
he's what
lucky is that what you said thank you oh
[__] you're not going to diction me
okay
it's in Nashville I bet your [__] smell
like Copenhagen long cup okay foreign
[Applause]
[Music]